MUSLIMS BECAUSE OF THEIR
RELIGION, UPHOLDING A RULING BY
A FEDERAL JUDGE IN MARYLAND.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS ALREADY
AGREED TO HEAR THE TRAVEL BAN
CASE IN APRIL.
>>> PLENTY OF ACTION IN THE U.S.
SENATE ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IS ANYTHING BEING ACCOMPLISHED?
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE IS ON THE
HILL TODAY.
>> Reporter: THE SENATE VOTED ON
MULTIPLE PLANS, BUT MANY FELL
SHORT OF THE THRESHOLD WITH JUST
39 SENATORS VOTING IN FAVOR OF A
TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT PITCH.
>> THIS IS IT, IN A SENSE.
ONLY PLAN THAT CAN BECOME LAW.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
WOULD SIGN IT.
>> Reporter: JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
CHUCK GRASSLEY SIGNED THE PLAN
FAVORED BY THE WHITE HOUSE AND
LEADING REPUBLICANS, AND
PROVIDED A 12-YEAR PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR 1.8 MILLION
SO-CALLED DREAMERS, AND MORE
MANPOWER AND A WALL.
FAMILY BASED MIGRATION TO THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY, AND PHASE OUT
THE VIS A LOTTERY SYSTEM.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S MADE CLEAR
AND I STRONGLY AGREE THAT ANY
LEGISLATION MUST ALSO TREAT THE
ROOT CAUSES AND REFORM LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
IT MUST ALSO INCLUDE
COMMON-SENSE STEPS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SHARED HIS THOUGHTS ON TWITTER
THIS MORNING, WHILE THE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS ARE WORKING HARD TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION TO DACA.
THEY SHOULD BE STRONGLY
CONSIDERING A SYSTEM OF
MERIT-BASED IMMIGRATION, SO THAT
WE WILL HAVE THE PEOPLE READY,
WILLING AND ABLE TO HELP ALL
TOSS COMPANIES MOVING INTO THE
USA.
THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
MEDDLING.
>> THERE'S ONLY ONE REASON WHY
THE SENATE WILL BE UNABLE TO
REACH A BIPARTISAN SOLUTION TO
DACA, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Reporter: THERE WAS ALSO A
BIPARTISAN PLAN NEGOTIATED BY 22
SENATORS WHICH WAS ATTACKED BY
THE WHITE HOUSE, INCLUDING A
VETO THREAT AND THE PRESIDENT
WARNING IT WOULD BE A TOTAL
CATASTROPHE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WARNED IT WOULD BE,
QUOTE, "THE END OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT IN AMERICA."
>> THE RELEASE WAS SO OVER THE
TOP, AND INFLAMMATORY, NOT
FACTUAL.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
TAKEN THAT SERIOUSLY.
WE'RE THE SENATE OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WE'RE THE ARTICLE 1 BRANCH.
WE DON'T HAVE TO PLAY MOTHER MAY
I WITH ANYBODY.
>> Reporter: VENTING FRUSTRATION
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S INNER
CIRCLE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, LISTEN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND LEAD US IN
CONGRESS AND ALL WILL TURN OUT
WELL.
IF HE TURNS THIS AGENDA OVER TO
THE MOST EXTREME PEOPLE ON THIS
OBAMA AND BUSH.
>> Reporter: DEDICATED TO
SOLVING THIS ISSUE, A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY.
>> OFFERING A PATHWAY FOR
CITIZENSHIP FOR 1.8 MILLION DACA
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING, BUT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE UP, BECAUSE
THE DEADLINE IS STILL MARCH THE
5th, AND THE CLOCK IS TICKING.
>> Reporter: SENATE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS SOUND RELUCTANT TO BURN
MORE TIME ON THIS ISSUE.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY THE
FIGHT NOW SHIFTS TO THE HOUSE
WHERE THEY BELIEVE LEADERSHIP IS
GETTING CLOSER TO GETTING ENOUGH
VOTES FOR THE MORE CONSERVATIVE
PLAN FROM HOUSE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN BOB GOODLATTE.
>> Bret: QUICKLY, MIKE, IF THE
HOUSE PASSES THAT, THAT IS MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAN THE GRASSLEY
BILL WAS THAT FAILED TODAY.
>> Reporter: IT WOULD APPEAR TO
HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF HOW